people with severe mental illnesses have
up to a 20-year shorter life expectancy
than their general population well this
means that some people living with
bipolar disorder or schizophrenia have
the same life expectancy of someone
living in the 1950s this is all for a
report by the Royal College of
Psychiatrists and public health England
which is calling for more to be done to
address this situation well-being talk
now to Andrew Gordon who's a Labour
councillor for Basildon and lives with
schizophrenia and Angie thank you very
much for coming in to talk to us about
this and it's quite shocking isn't it
somebody with a mental health issues
expected to live 20 years less than
those who don't live with it what do you
think some of the factors that play off
I think one of the big ones is of course
when you're put on medication medication
can make you put on quite a lot of
weight and of course IB City can have a
lot of effects the other one is of
course smoking you know when you're life
it when you're really really struggling
in life a cigarette is that you know is
is is that too much to ask for I don't
know and I think the other one is of
course suicide you know the biggest
killer for me as a guy under the age of
45 is I'm likely to kill myself so I
think those three factors combined and
probably make it really difficult for
someone I mean I've got 20 years off my
life I'm not sure how I'm how I feel
about that no not not to happy I would
imagine so this report is highlighting
this issue and trying to get something
done to address it talk to me about
living with schizophrenia because you're
quite keen to share your experience and
often where we talk about mental health
issues on Sunrise it's always about men
who don't want to talk about it whereas
the perception is women talk about it
more freely and therefore get more help
I think it's important to talk about it
firstly and any opportunity I have to
talk about it I will I think what what
it's like living with a mental health
condition I think if you add had any
health condition it's like a spectrum
you know you you're well you're unwell
you're you you flux a bad day days badly
yeah I would argue I haven't healthier
mental health than most people in the
country because I know how to manage my
health if you had a heart condition and
your doctor said to you okay you know
you've got to get healthy and if you
don't get help you don't start
physically exercising you're gonna die
chances are you can
start becoming physically healthy for me
I need to be mentally healthy because if
I'm not the consequences are quite
severe so that includes self-harm that
includes suicidal ideations so sometimes
I will obsess about killing myself
sometimes I'll wake up and pretty much
every half an hour I will think about
killing myself and at the extreme end I
can start here having auditory
hallucinations so hearing voices and
that's quite a scary experience
delusions paranoia which is some of the
symptoms of schizophrenia that people
know the most about I would imagine
also stress although that seems like a
silly thing to say if you have that
condition you're in a state of stress
all the time which is a massive
contributor to to death yeah I mean
imagine someone talking in your ear
constantly that that's what it's like
you know that's like having me have that
it's like a running commentary wasn't
the timing I don't experience those
symptoms now because I'm keeping myself
well but I know if I'm not keeping
myself well that's that's what it could
end up as that's what that's the path I
can end up going down and the thing that
frustrates me the most is that I can't
get help early on so I know my signs and
symptoms I know when I'm becoming unwell
I know when I actually have to say to
myself
Andrew you need to take a step back but
if I go to my doctor
he's got my place to refer me I'm not
unwell enough to actually get the help
yourself
essentially oh yeah I mean you know I
mean I have some really dark days
sometimes but I've even got a choice and
I'm gonna paraphrase the Shawshank
Redemption I can either get busy living
or get busy dying because if I made the
decision to give in and you know you
know be surrounded by these really
depressing dark Falls then to be honest
I may as well jump of a building but I
think I make the decision to fight fire
every single day and it's interesting
you know that the report says you know
people like me are gonna die 20 years
younger well actually I could have died
when I was a lot younger and every
single day I'm living now
is a gift to me it's a day that I
wouldn't have had well Andrew it's
really interesting to hear you speak and
I know that you are talking to a lot of
people not just on television
you know from they your message
personally and putting the message that
it's okay to talk about mental health
and parcel minute and ask for help so
thank you very much for showing your
story with us here and sunrise this
morning Andrew Gordon there basil don't
label labour councillor